the clear leader of the tournament
wesley saw is joining us wesley you've
switched a little bit not a berlin but a
petrov where did your knowledge on here
oh yeah before we talk about the game
just want to say first of all uh
very pleased to win and all glory to god
of course for giving me the win
um
yeah the petrov is twofold basically
fabiano played it against me the other
day
and so i thought i tried with the other
side uh secondly we had the rest day
yesterday
and hans prepares extremely extremely
well the openings like sometimes we can
even predict
so i thought why not the petrov also if
you check on the database he doesn't
have
like he has hundreds of games with
knight v6 for both colors meanwhile the
petrol he only has a few
and he generally
plays
very tedious lines like he plays knight
d3 on mob4
and so i thought i'd try it today but um
um yeah it worked out well i mean
obviously i just
wanna play solid today and with all the
drama just try to survive
but hans was obviously playing for a win
as he said he would uh but i think i was
i equalized well in the opening like he
didn't play the most
critical lines i'm not sure where his
preparation ended maybe it ended on move
15 when he played bishop e5
um and here
i had a similar position where if white
plays bishop e5 then you play knight e4
knight f6 to
because the d5 pawn is the only problem
right i mean black has other moves but i
thought this equalizes
uh well
maybe
he can try
like on a queen f5 or something
like queen f5 g6 queen h3
and try to start up something of course
this should be nothing i'm sure the
engine gives all zeroes
but um in the game after i play g6a6 i
see no problems for black because he
doesn't have any
any place to create
anything and i mean if he plays like
knight f5 in two minutes then
then whatever but i don't think knight
f5 works no i meant like when i played
g6 ah knight f5 here whoa yeah i thought
knight f5 gf5 and then knight h4 um oh
no not takes not h4 that makes more
sense actually but then just knight g7
oh wait
wait so the point is after knight g7
you're playing knight f5
yeah this is not that clear actually
yeah maybe not knight g7 yeah maybe not
knight so i think knight e4 94 knight
knight f5 and then some f6 f6 maybe
bishop f6 or maybe bishop of six yeah
huh
bishop f6 two yeah right but and then
yeah sorry for something like this
because they don't have g3 even if it
did something yeah but yeah and the game
was very tedious and i thought h4 by the
way were you surprised about this move
g3
no because he wants to take take ncd5
without having to worry about knight for
like if white once
you fight once the door you can take on
f6 and then cd5 i guess knight f4 queen
e4 and then just play this the structure
yeah i mean it's completely equal
so i mean yeah i didn't chose the most
critical lines i thought h4 was a
blender because after knight h5 his
bishop is getting trapped right and i
didn't see a way for him to equalize
here like
he could sacrifice a piece with knight
g4 then i play f6
then
he can he thought he could give a check
or he can play rook batter ugly when i
can play like bishop f8 or something or
queen d7 and i think black's better in
all life but
yeah we also felt like that i will tell
you that there was a way to equalize the
position yeah i didn't see a way to
equalize after knight h5 yeah after cd
cd you might not believe it but it's b4
ah
yeah i would i wouldn't know the
reaction i wanted to get
before yeah that's that's exactly the
reaction yeah yeah and f6 when bit three
yes
no it's still messy after that the
computer says zeros but of course
and the point is that you don't want to
play queen d7 because after 27 knight g4
f6 he always gains a tempo attacking the
queen no i think i think we were playing
queen b3 rook g8
like i didn't even see this bishop b8 it
just it's so hard to find moves like
that but i guess that's almost
impossible okay i have an engine
and not not a strong engine it's not a
strong engine but it still sees very
good moves yeah b4 i assume
i don't know maybe magnus would find b4
i don't know he's a pretty strong player
tell us a little bit about this endgame
you got all the way here it felt like
your opponent was under a lot of
pressure you exchanged the rooks there
was not a lot of choices at one point a
line also on move 26
like uh instep knight takes f4 i thought
he could play hg hg knight e5 fe 5
knight f4 ef4
and then um
so
rook
uh if h5 i have broke g8 i guess and
then bishop f6 yeah it's nice that it's
a chuck and so instead of hype you can
play rook the e1
rook d-e-1 uh-huh pinning but i think
queen s8 is winning for black queen c8
and you have this important move queen
g4 coming in to defend everything yeah
and unpinning rook e6 queen takes
through yeah this is too much material
but i think if i don't have queen v8 i'm
not winning oh really yeah i think we've
dreamed only 26 h5 or yeah queen e6 h5
well let me put this quick queen d6 h5
in this position and now i assume rookie
6 is the idea no hd thick ihd under your
bishop is hanging so i mean i can make a
draw with rook 8 or something right any
passing move is actually a draw yeah you
can see it yeah but i mean but why would
when he played h4 i wanted to try to
yeah but i mean i thought he would go
for
some line like this but i think
it doesn't work so did you think the end
game was that bad for him
um i i thought it's unpleasant
but i
of course it's uh not clear if you're
gonna win like i think maybe
in the game i was regretting when i
played bishop f4 i thought the winning
plan here well the winning plan is too
much but i thought the best plan is to
play bishop before yes actually the
angels were very adamant about this move
as well yeah the thing is i could play
bishop before earlier but if i put
bishop on d6
but i think bishop b4
and then basically
the knight cannot move because
begin in the game he got queen city and
some counterparts he fell but i think
bishop b4 with very good chances the
points you play queen e4 and then king
e6 king f5 when you're four kings 165
right and the knight is controlled
yeah i didn't play this because i
thought i didn't see a win after king e2
queen e4
when takes d takes knight g1
or is it knight g1 and then f but it's
gonna be winning yeah so yeah it's all
pretty bad king e16 e3
en i didn't find a win here but it looks
bad for black i mean it's like similar
to half the game right and in the game
when did you feel that you finally had
it all under control
no actually i messed it up like
around 30
so around move 34 to 38 i was just
shuffling my pieces yes like i wasn't
sure where to put my king whether to
bring in h5 but it doesn't do anything
or taking all the way to h5 right looks
pretty yeah yeah it looks pretty bad
doesn't do anything
but also
like i wasn't sure where to put my
king so around move 39 i was actually
figuring that it's probably gonna be
very very
difficult to win this and you know if
it's a door it's a draw that's fine
because i would have been happy with the
draw anyway before the game but i
thought um
kingito on mode42 was a serious blender
right and you capitalized on it
yeah he probably missed bishop h2
after which i didn't see a draw anymore
yeah and you were absolutely correct now
that it says for 93 bishop f4 it seems
the end game is just lost yeah i'm very
sharply playing it too because he's got
50 minutes
on the clock
and
any move
is very solid for white
okay you have to defend a little bit but
uh
i mean i'm not sure what white can play
like i think the edges were thinking
knight e2
ah
and then yeah king e6 knights
fifth 15 e6
it still looks very very dangerous to my
eyes it's definitely
yeah maybe maybe attack on h3 it
definitely is dangerous but hope for
survival king 82 seems like bishop h2
finished off the game
yeah he probably missed it like he was
calculating bishop f4 queen right
winning four d for f3 now this is very
clever because the knight is actually
worst place on f3 that is on g1 yeah and
if he plays knight h3 i have in this
position
well they're happy king d6 something
yeah i think kingdom 6 was the end of
the main movie
yeah yeah
yeah so
king e2 was just a shocker okay h4 was
also a shocker so hans made two blenders
today yeah wesley a nice win with the
black pieces you are now in pole
position do you feel you're ready to win
your second sing phil cup
oh one one game at that time
but first of all i'd like to thank the
many people like the saint louis chess
club
also the anti cheating team so like tony
rich
joy bray
also
uh to the arbiters chris bird
and
of course to rex and jeannie singfield
by the way related happy birthday to him
and uh yeah to you guys also to
alejandro and
peter and yasser for
all the considerate things that you do
every day i mean obviously this
tournament is
a bit messed up with
magnus withdrawing but hey he's the best
player so i'm fine with that but i'm
really grateful for
the things that people did to secure
this tournament i mean
of course i feel sorry for hans is only
19 and there's a tremendous amount of
pressure coming from everybody and we
still
don't know 100 what
really happened or anything but
my mother had a talk with tony rich on
the
with
the day before and he said the security
here is
even better than the white house after
he said that i was very pleased with
i'm really grateful to the people who
made this tournament here well that is a
big claim we certainly appreciate it you
make our lives easy because you play
these wonderful games like the one you
did today
yeah i mean
sometimes you
are happy to make a drone you win
sometimes you try to win and you can't
make progress so that's just how chess
goes indeed well wesley thank you for
this and uh good luck in the rest of
your tournament yeah i have a rest day
tomorrow that's also very also not bad
yeah we go
go watch the movies have a nice meal try
to get the 12 hours of sleep and that
will be preparation of course for youth
yes probably in the most winning what is
that sorcery that yeah i don't
understand she had 12 hours of sleep
yeah that's
possible i haven't done that yeah
if you wanna
sleep for 12 hours you have to lie in
bed for 14 hours
well there's a secret to success guys 12
hours of sleep 14 hours of bad rest
yeah that's why it's called rest days
not really
very good all right thank you wesley for
joining us here thank you guys back to
you
thank you wesley for